[Music]
let's talk her own a virus is my mama
what's happening is I am in Japan there
are currently 214 total confirmed cases
with the total of 4 deaths but 22 have
recovered I have a look that's its
goodness I have a live map in front of
me that's from the John Hopkins
University who's that who's that NBA
basketball sorry do you have a live map
I want it later ok there are in mainland
China 78,000 holy [ __ ]
Jase is not dead skating yeah yeah 2788
dead that's still wild so like a 2%
death rats really thousand you know what
that calls me that tells me I need it by
cleaning stock cuz I'm good a lot of
people runny noses or face masks two to
three percent death rate okay
that's less than the flu similar to the
flu a rate less Norfolk but but but big
thing that's been missing a lot of this
reporting uh-huh is that the the
contagious like the amend the ability
for the virus to get into another person
is three times higher than the foot in
the flu that's why it's important to
wash your heat so you know everyone
likes to say media sensationalizing this
I think there's a degree of that always
it's happening no matter what the [ __ ]
me is talking about but if it's three
times that of our flu 23 million people
had the flu in 2019 2020 season flu
season okay maybe 60 something million
exactly so once you get to 2 percent 3
percent of that dying you know you're
talking about a million people maybe or
you know under a million people assumes
you're not working anymore cuz usually
you just boil some ginger and you sweat
it out we had a doctor here that
explained this to you but you didn't
listen
oh yeah I forgot
should be as scared is what you say no I
think that we should be scared of the
contagiousness lethal so when you go on
to airplane fly like this if that
doesn't work because that of eighty
three thousand three hundred and forty
two confirmed cases thirty six thousand
498 have been recovered well that's good
which is really good but we also don't
know so apparently there's also some
some difference of there's a really
caught there's a rate of people getting
it again oh wow that we're just starting
to understand because some people who
had it are now getting it again so we're
not quite sure yet but that's also part
of so what's [ __ ] is the media if
the media didn't have to speak about it
in sensationalist terms like for example
I would sell a lot of you guys this
morning and it's now the evening
there's a big story that says like oh
well there was of somebody in California
who could tract a corn of hours while
not being ever in Wuhan they never
travel they didn't go anywhere so it
almost seems like they just got it
randomly
oh that sounds to be reported right yeah
but if you go to [ __ ] paragraphs down
in the Washington Post article it says
even the CDC says they must have been in
contact with somebody who's like on a
cruise ship or something but the
sensationalist headline is what makes me
suspect the media for for
sensationalizing the disease it has
nothing to do with anything about the
disease itself why does the media need
to sensationalize something like that
okay it seemed like a guy in California
just randomly got out of nowhere which
which is what they say in the headline
but then when you read the article
that's how long how irresponsible it's
just lame right you know no one's
reading articles these days they just
want to clickbait titles just like let's
watch JK news twitter had bought it so
what um I know the OSI declared a state
of emergency but how many cases did they
have because I mean we're like Italy
declared a state of emergency after had
like two people no but but what three
people died seventeen seventeen well
it's growing guys updated that was two
hundred something like a couple days ago
no
just earlier it was like for something
when just this morning when I checked
what's growing and growing but no no it
has actually receded since it the
outbreak happened as far as the level
the level of outbreak has receded good
now that doesn't mean that we're out of
the woods at all because I this Korean
lady she was an airline attendant
I guess she from Korean airline into LA
what are they doing to all the flight
attendants like are they giving them
masks or anything because they're the
ones that are like getting are going to
be acceptable fine optimal maybe he'll
let us know in the group test when I'm
on the I let me tell you something I was
pissed at that lady because she they
listed all the restaurants she went to
in k-town so they like eats a lot huh
she went to like five different
restaurants when she was here all the
best one she order k-town restaurants
she why is your Chili's Cho laps I mean
what kind of person goes to a country
and they eat your own cultures food when
you get there but I heard k-town
arguably has better food than Korea
though that's what I've heard
it does though I bid by fog okay but I
was mad because she went to a restaurant
called honey pig which I've been trying
to go to and now I'm like the Korean
barbecue place I don't know what it is
gonna linger I was in Elliot's on
Valentine's Day so were you tip was she
there man yeah I was engaged on like
last week too so she was there from um
um so she said flight attendant work
flights between Los Angeles and in
Incheon yeah on February 19th 20th yes
okay I don't care I mean you seem help
also service the flight from Tel Aviv to
Seoul on February 15
but that wasn't here okay good tel Aviv
but he gestured at me so I had to say so
which flight got her sick which that's
the key what you're asking about
okay in the u.s. there are 60 confirmed
cases six people have recovered yes two
in Chicago one in San Diego one in Santa
Clara Clara one in Seattle one in
Italy's crazy LAX check the ones I just
named are recovered oh right so now we
have the alias chick who just got it so
um we don't know what can
level she [ __ ] spy restaurant how she
worked with people and none of the other
people got it it's just her so for that
we have it but no Center seems to be a
long incubation period sometimes I think
they've said up to 15 21 days yeah like
two weeks or something so that is what
makes people go oh [ __ ] we don't even
know what we're dealing I might have had
Corona maybe you did my associate lands
into the airport tonight and my dad he
texted me he's like she comes back
tonight and I was like yeah he's like
he's like keep her in her room for two
weeks before you like Hey before you
kiss her to do anything just to make
sure there's a little bow-wow don't
worry you don't have to be scared cuz
two three percent well also by the way I
have to clarify that so it's two or
three percent in so far in certain
countries in some countries it's as high
as five six percent and and uh like it
depends on their level of medical and if
they're doing a good by the way by the
way so this is part of what I'm saying
where I say okay oh I don't like how the
media sensationalizes things but if
we're dealing with a pandemic where you
have three times the amount of people
getting sick
then the flu 22 million people last year
times three that's a lot of people
you're going to be able to treat that
many people at the same time in a
hospital yeah actually telling people to
stay home and try to recover on your own
true and does a death rate go from two
three percent to higher yeah I think so
so that's when things get very [ __ ]
scary and so I don't think that people
are wrong for saying that this is scary
because of that yeah reowww that makes
sense we are definitely scary so just be
careful out there man like if you're
traveling I mean apparently you can't
even wear a [ __ ] mask and be safe
because you get on the outside and still
won't touch your mask and you didn't
wash your hands now your mask is
contagious or what emanating what if you
take your mask off like this TIFF I just
divine I'm more scared of coughing and
being Asian they say they say the masks
are more for keeping your germs from
getting bad
you don't want to be coughing while
Asian on the airplane oh dude I know let
me tell you something ignorant a speaker
I know to the point where I have like
little masks that I mean I was wearing
before just cuz I think they look cool
and I was like I'm gonna win the airport
cuz now I finally have an excuse to wear
the mask now people are gonna be crazy
right and then I realized I was looking
around everybody wearing the masks are
[ __ ] Asian I was like let me not
freak out these like not Asian people
just take my [ __ ] mask on you know I
just say it was always Asian people
wearing masks I know but that's when it
was like a fashion thing oh and just cuz
you know it's a lot of smog out there in
those Asian is not what it was yeah I
always saw Asian ladies wear a mask
always yeah since 2003 damn so it's been
doing this since the 90s yeah there's so
smoggy out there from all those little
water bikes so the CDC has warned men
about their facial hair dangers oh thank
god and I shaved now they have this like
little thingy here and they're showing
you facial hair styles and filtering
facepiece respirators so they're showing
you like what kind of facial hair you
should be having for your your
respirators yo funny [ __ ] about this
chart is every single beard style has a
name yeah this is French Fork this is
like villain there's the chin curtain
CDC do they have a Hitler one no they
actually call it toothbrush hey do the
Hitler one [ __ ] love official [ __ ]
there's Zorro
villo here's villain has a little curly
at the bottom oh wow that's funny I've
never seen Hitler the villain one pulled
off well I've never seen it white
hipster dudes Kim Chi yeah the ones that
were the ones that were the new Bart
hats and like you're talking about
Bart's [ __ ] golf head yeah that one
tangle the Kangol right I don't know if
it's ever worked though luckily I can't
grow any of these so not a sick girl oh
girl this is me after like a month
really he's so lucky I just shaved this
morning by girl Oh
doing any of these no you have to on the
sides here no Timmy D are you scared to
travel tomorrow like legit I wouldn't
say I'm scared I'm a little bit scared
I'm traveling Saturday it's in the back
of your mind you know I'm saying but
it's awesome I hand sanitizer I have my
disinfecting wipes I also have a high
immune system I think have a strong
immune system so uh and I'm definitely
you know I don't I tweeted the other day
I was like anybody that's gonna see me
at playlist live I'm not shaking no
hands we're gonna just keep it at daps
especially fear from Wu Han okay or
anywhere you know it's I just got sick
so I'm like [ __ ] it
yeah so yeah you're immune now yeah I'm
talking them all too but I'm coming from
birthday you're getting it twice you
shouldn't be that way week hey week son
I'm traveling from Burbank so that's the
part that's crazy because you usually
can't catch the same flu twice because
what if it's a viral infection your body
develops antibody to the antigen and
then it learns so you don't ever get to
evolve Corona exactly came by the way we
don't even know if this is Corona 19 or
some [ __ ]
and by the way corona virus is a [ __ ]
it's in your [ __ ] lungs in your face
rotor we're gonna kill so that doesn't
mean it's done the nineteenth version is
what this is that the seven versions or
whatever so who knows it really is scary
there it is they say Mary is the kid is
the [ __ ] rate that you can
communicate it to somebody else so be
wary of that don't cough or sneeze into
your hands rise sweeps sleeves alone or
this you can live that's pretty cool
drink orange juice yeah don't don't stop
doing that so if you're watching this on
a Carnival Cruise Line right now and
you're in your quarantine hey just know
yeah
you might live yeah did in a whole ship
get quarantine and they're just are they
still living there they're still out
there thinking are they in the [ __ ]
on the ship are the other ships though
oh yeah that live map thing that I
showed higher close already but it does
show like under and
of a country's as other and that's from
the cruise ships whoa
and apparently it communicated pretty
well in that environment like a lot it
was 705 from that cruise ships that's
[ __ ] scary four deaths on the Diamond
Princess cruise tender color how many
people on the cruise do you think all of
them got sick to twelve hundred or
something yeah that was seven hundred
exactly so that's what I'm saying it's
very [ __ ] potay just kidding from one
person to another so that's what we got
to be careful but I'm gonna wear my mask
even though they say it doesn't do
anything I'm definitely gonna be masked
up tomorrow oh yeah I'm gonna wear a
[ __ ] ninja mask I would just wear a
[ __ ] hole and tired dive is scuba
diving where Donald Trump man yeah hey
there you go everyone stays away from me
[Music]